they sit there
i gotta put you guys a little further
back we're tall in this household
oh my gosh
oh my goodness
um
we have a creamer
uh oh yeah
where right here yeah there's coconuts
wait this is creamer
well i use it as creamer okay i was like
i used this in my smoothie the other day
they can be used
okay
do we have stevia too uh we should we're
[Music]
yeah so this is the live stream
and then
i used to watch every morning during
election season
but no it's not election season so you
just gotta wait because
is this
did i see a chunk come out of this
you have to shake it a little bit okay
it's brand new okay i was a little
nervous
okay
i prefer almond milk and
i like what you call it um
i really like soy milk but it's higher
in calories so i choose almond
or oats
feels kind of dirt like it tastes dirty
down really yeah i like it
okay guys
good morning put your questions in the
chat
you just give it a second
um
cold oh maybe
okay
i'm trying to convince my mom to buy me
a piano today
um
she thinks just because i'm 25 she can't
find any things anymore which i think is
false
[Music]
oh my god
i need more sugar or creamer or
something how did that work after you
redid it
oh did you put the
honey what did you put the k-cup back in
here yeah oh fine okay
yeah she just made it like no no no
no it was it was it just poured out
water so yeah
okay mom
do you think that dating is harder today
than it was when you were younger for
sure why um
there's too many options you think so
is there someone that i should have
picked by now
um
who would you have picked for my husband
oh i don't know that i have a person in
mind no one no one from like childhood
um
yeah
a farmer
why a farmer
uh
the world is collapsing and they can do
anything
you think the world's gonna collapse
i think it is
okay
it's going to um
so why a farmer over like
i don't know um
like a business owner or something i
don't know
okay
or like i just want you to keep your
work out there
thank you she's taking shots in my last
relationship
[Laughter]
i was staged there i was like dude i
don't think i do view i did not make you
say that wait let me wipe the camera off
i think it's a little boy
oh wow that looks so much better
okay
so my mom wants me to end up with a
farmer
that works hard
who loves earth
it doesn't have to be a farmer doesn't
have to be a farmer mom we don't even
recycle
is there recycling here we recycle a lot
in florida okay we can't recycle okay we
recycle at one of our four houses
and we're recycling castle oh do we when
okay do you think that dating is harder
for men or for women
because you have sons and daughters
um
i think dating is hard for moms
for moms
it's hard to watch it
wait why is it why is it hard to watch
because there's
like the girls out there all a bunch of
hoochie things and
the boys like they just everybody gives
their bodies away
well i stayed there
that's true that's true
did you feel like when you had like your
greg with dad you were became more
attached to him because i heard you
release a hormone when you have a kid
with someone
um no i don't i don't
i would not say that
really you don't think so
no okay
did um are you glad
when you moved in college for dad would
you recommend like i did that
um
i'm glad because my new college my
college i had a lot of fun
in my new calendar no i just want the
idea of like moving for a guy oh
um because i think it made me feel bad
about myself to be honest with you oh
really
so you want to tell me to move for a guy
no i mean
not as an adult maybe but not as a
college kid
oh not as a college kid
[Music]
did anyone tell you not to do that
grandma i thought it was your sister
well it worked out
who gets the final laugh with your four
houses
and 10 kids
would you ever
give up your social media
uh
yeah really
yeah
you don't really post like you used to
now i only use it as a diary so i post
like once a month and i go back and
vacate everything
and only about half of my posts i post
publicly like i only post the things
publicly that are like that people want
pictures or something you think social
media makes relationships harder
why is it you think because of like
other people's opinions
um i think because it just puts pressure
it puts false pressure on people how
long do you think you should date
someone before you put them on your
social media
um
i that's like something that wasn't in
my generation so i don't know well you
guys have facebook
no we didn't
you know when i did facebook like i had
seven kids probably well no i'm saying
like
you friends that dated right while you
had they had facebook no
no okay no i was like 40.
facebook came up really you're not old
i mean i don't know
i know the first thing i saw on facebook
was my cousin my nephew bobby was
getting married wow that's the very
first thing i saw on facebook i think i
put the sugar
oh here's another one you're using it as
your
kitty stand
oh
did you ever have myspace someone asked
oh no no
i really wish i brought my
camera holder or my phone holder but i
forgot it
okay um
live chat okay
um
i'm gonna bring you guys a little
further back
it's gonna be super hard to make crepes
where you're making your coffee
okay wait wait wait hold up hold up
i really wish
this is a struggles we call this we call
these struggle strangers mom
oh this is better okay
[Music]
do you think it's a wife's duty to stay
in shape for her husband i think it's
every spouse's duty do you think it's a
husband's duty too yes
i think that we all have to take care of
our own health before we can take care
of anybody else's health but that's good
and like when you're not happy with your
body you're not nice to other people
yeah
like i don't think so at least i'm not
anyways
they want to know how your morning's
going
um
you know i slept terrible last night so
i got up in the middle of it and watched
the shooting stars
oh really yeah looks
uh
snow is so crunchy in the middle of the
night it's so awesome
so i'm going to be tired i'm sure
would you pick out a different spouse
for me than for gabrielle and eva like
would you want all of us to date farmers
um i would say yeah
yeah why why
why do why do you think i would go well
with a farmer
um actually that was probably i don't
know why
eva
you need somebody who's really organized
someone really organized because like
you lived in an organized house but you
don't have that skill set so well and
i'm a good listener i'm a good listener
i'm really i've always had bosses and
coaches like me maybe not teachers but
that's because i didn't care
um would you care if your grandkids were
next yes
did you know i was on um a
show once that said i was tainted
after i dated a black guy
i've heard that before
morning dad
just so you know i wasn't offended by
the vegetables don't ask me if i was
offended um
do you want a breakfast burrito
[Music]
why is this coffee so bad
i keep trying to put more sugar stuff in
it but like it doesn't help
i don't know because i don't drink
coffee
oh i'll take a crepe
oh you owe me that
nutella and peanut butter crepe nutella
and peanut butter
[Music]
i need a haircut
you see it split ends i have i've got a
haircut in like six months oh yeah
should i keep trying or should i quit on
the coffee
i'd start over
okay
sometimes in life quitting is the right
thing to do
oh how long do you think you should work
in an idea before putting at it like
when do you think it's it's just a bad
idea
like in business
oh that's hard
it all depends on the idea i would say
well i know but
maybe two years
two years and if you've seen like no
progress in two years i think what you
have to do is
you have to create exactly what your
mission statement is and what measurable
goals you have
and then make sure you're progressing
toward it
so now that you should put an idea
necessarily
did you know that 80 of women want 20 of
them did you know that um you've told me
that before i'm not crazy i thought that
was the craziest stat i've ever heard of
my life but then i found out only
fifteen percent of guys are six foot and
i was like taller
[Music]
guys put questions in the chat put
questions in the chat okay
more water
oh my gosh i hit the green last night
but it delivered a baby
really
i was thinking about you how much of
your life you spent pregnant
14 years
14 years old pregnant or breastfeeding
like basically not in control of my body
for 14 years are you done having kids
what were you done having kids
what age yeah
37 wow when was your first oh 17 but
then when did you have austin because
there was like a gap
he was 23.
wow so you really were having kids for
forever did you like being pregnant
well did you take the plastic off the
tip
oh this one's not good
you didn't like being pregnant
i was just sick all the time there's no
like warm feeling where like you just
feel so kind of sick all the time
how short is too short
um
give or take your height
so like 5 eight
too short two shorts i have ten eleven
yeah
five ten is okay you're too short it's
okay
five nine
that's what i said actually i said five
ten or taller
um
was your high school boyfriend taller
than you yeah
he looks like my brother jason
[Music]
me
the chat says you're cute i don't know
why this always happens i am so what
about me
like
does that is that flat are you are you
like excited by these comments i think
it's cute like
it's funny
i'm old
so yeah when you're 50 years old
you're pretty excited
is your mom single
um
did he ever oh my gosh yeah he did
upload the exposal video yesterday
it was actually pretty good to be honest
i was a fan
someone decided to make like a exposed
video on me where like they exposed me
okay what does that mean
and they called me a jezebel spirit do
you know what that is uh kind of yeah i
know who jasmine bible is
she's not a yeah it's like i think i'm
like i said i have like the devil in me
and i need to have an exorcism
so um i was thinking that would be a fun
youtube video i was like sign me up
like i'm not
if they exercise me and i don't have a
demon in me like it'll just be for fun
right
let's not go there
i'm not sure how i feel about all of
that but like you just don't want to
tempt
it was funny because the guy didn't even
listen to what i was saying
like he did not
oh my god
most people are dead listeners well i
was like
i was saying that the mammosphere talk
like has you worrying about things you
can't change
and don't worry about things you can't
change
and he was saying well she's saying like
you should do whatever you want and like
girls can get away with anything i was
like what the [ __ ] no
what are you talking about okay
um
okay guys put your questions in the chat
i'm gonna give this a try
i'm not sure how i feel about this whole
thing
um
do you know who laura prep on prepping
is
no i don't know
i said i have her vibe
can you put some butter in my coffee i'm
trying again
can i put butter in it i'm making you a
crepe
oh so those are just
wow that's interesting those crepes yeah
i mean i don't know i've never done this
before so
i've never seen a like a pre-made crepe
i've never seen one either
how tall is everyone in my family so
adam six four awesome six three
chaz is six foot
um
greg is what six four
six three
um
i'm i'm six foot gabrielle's what five
ten
type ten um
ebay's five
eight amelia is what five nine five five
ten five ten
butter is gonna shorten your life
expectancy i have to live a life without
butter it's not a life worth living
we get irish butter sauce
what do i think the pros and cons are of
the manosphere um i think the pros is
that it gives men like a spate like
you know girls have feminism and men
have had the equivalent of that before
it
um i think the cons is that it has guys
worrying about [ __ ] you can't change
so for example
um
you can't change your height and like
there's a lot of stats that make it
pretty
grim for men if like you're under a
certain height
or
you can't really change i mean do you
think people can really change their
personality
because i feel like and you're older
than me so maybe you have a different
opinion on this but i feel like if a guy
is genuinely like a nice guy like
and more of like they call him data that
you can like do things to maybe work on
it a little bit but you can't change
someone's whole personality
and why now being nice is bad no it's
not being bad it's like girls don't want
a guy that like they can walk all over
okay you know what i'm saying like
you've always seen a husband that's like
like he does everything like for the
wife and that doesn't really turn on me
and i need it anyway okay but like that
doesn't make them like respect him you
know like like a good
leader has the ability to say no
does that make sense yeah and but i feel
like um a lot of guys want to be like in
the man of scare like alpha are like the
leader or whatever i just think they
need weaker women then i think you just
there's women that go with them
there are women that don't want that
would be
swallowed alive
like uncle joe was absolutely the wrong
person transmission
she was like
a um
she was like a butterfly
a butterfly
okay
that's yours
hey hannah it doesn't look good but
tastes really good okay
um
oh the girl from that 70s show you can
be a nice guy and have a backbone no but
that's what i'm saying mom i think
you're misunderstanding like
i'm talking about guys that like don't
have a backbone okay
i'm saying like
i'm just saying that there's probably
women that match up to that i don't
think some sixty percent of men don't
reproduce fun fact
or forty percent
oh jelly honey oh there's jelly in the
pantry and there's
they might open it
i'm gonna need to learn how to make a
crepes better but
okay
how many women don't produce
eight of 20 percent that's it
historically yeah
it's like 40 percent of memory produce
80 of them over time but
um it's the trends are actually going
more towards polygamy
so it'll be like a smaller percentage of
mine and like
um
not actual polygamy
i see all the time on social media
people need to go back to church i know
i'm not saying it's like
i'm not happy to say that like i think
it's weird
um talking about
king solomon had 700 wives that's crazy
what i don't even think he could meet
them all
i don't know
which is what the comment section saw
but i think i've heard that
okay well did you know like one out of
every 20 people in china
descended from king king
james something con genghis khan
okay look at that hannah
um
i made a crepe
this is really good actually
wow
yeah it didn't look good but
mine looks normal and it tastes good too
do you believe in like masculine and
feminine
roles
yes
do you feel like your feminine are more
masculine like what do you have to give
yourself
i would have wore a prom dress just to
work every day if it was appropriate
from what i found online i guess i have
a feminine like demeanor like i'm very
agreeable and
like when i talk but i'm kind of a
tomboy
it's okay though i can live with that
i actually do like wearing dresses i
just hate
i just hate spending a lot of time every
day getting ready like it exhausts me
and i feel like i can do something
better with that time
um
i'm black no i said china you didn't
descend from genghis khan yes you're not
asian
like
i don't know what the number was but it
was like 1 in 15 120 something like that
it was a pretty evil guy something
yeah
do you think it's appropriate to go out
to bars and stuff when you're married do
you think that's like ever inappropriate
because i know you you used to
but
i don't think it's inappropriate as long
as you're going
like a club
yeah that's what i think too i feel like
there's a big difference between a bar
and a club like if you're just going out
with girlfriends to have fun and dance
i would do that except for i don't stay
awake enough to do it
that's very frowned upon in the
nanosphere i didn't realize it but until
i started watching this content they're
like what is she doing like they just
want attention and i'm just like i don't
know it's fun sometimes girls just want
to go with girls like girls don't really
care that much
always about what the guys are doing
oh this is a little bit better than last
time the coffee
[Music]
almost there
they said it's because in your
generation that you actually had good
women but women in our generation like
they go to bars to cheat i think that's
actually probably pretty accurate
that's that i think it's accurate
like
my hometown is really common for me
to just go dancing
just had fun
you feel it
um guys put questions in the chat
um
[Music]
do you think if a girl has to pick
between a career or family what do you
think she should pick
it
[Music]
our natural predisposition is to have
children
i just feel like they should tell women
about like the cost of things
i don't necessarily think like girls
shouldn't
strive to like you know they should just
be housewives
but
i feel like a lot of times like the app
like feminism acts like there's no cost
you know yeah
that's what that was actually yeah
like they act like you can have
everything and you just can't well
you have to realize it comes with i mean
insanely hard work like there's some
people that do
but i feel like even if you have it all
like it still comes at a cost
sure you know like like you guys like i
feel like you had it all but like you
you guys had nannies and like i don't
think we would have survived without
nannies
and that was like your cost you know
right
which is fine like i liked i liked my
nannies but i mean everything in life
everybody cost
right oh we're catholic
um this is
a hate video on me yesterday
awesome
um
um
[Music]
mom do you
do you feel like it's a man's obligation
to make a woman happy during the
holidays
[Music]
[Laughter]
the opposite
i feel like you can't make another
person happy do you think you can make
do you think you can make someone happy
or they just have to be happy
do you know what mrcs are
mrcs said how do your parents feel about
mrcs and i don't know what that is
my phone's going live
[Laughter]
i can email the archbishop of your
diocese and see to it that nobody in
your family be given communion again
what did we do i don't know
he said invite him over for lunch
okay that's such a weird no the
entrepreneur
oh
do we know the archbishop
okay
[Music]
what advice would you guys give to young
businessmen
um
okay my dad says work hard and follow
your dreams my mom says make a plan
[Music]
my dad always told me to do things that
i'm interested in because if you're
interested in them then you become good
at them do you stand by that dad
what if you're interested in something
that makes no money do you still do it
i know what it is almost everything
even like music either eating to make
money and you make money in most things
but be sure there's some you can't like
feeding
boxes get that so straight up that you
are um someone said i may be the pope
one day and each woman will be tried
what about the men
[Laughter]
a lot of women wake up at 40 with no
kids or husband and they realize the men
don't care about a woman's career do you
think that's true
um
and i will call you oh my god what the
this guy said i will call you papa i
will put you into submission this is the
weirdest thing
um
mom he said it's the fear i'm gonna be
tried
um
uh what parent thought i was on only
fans oh i told my mom i was on only fans
to see her reaction once i don't even
know what it was
yeah she like she didn't she was like
what's only fans
i wish school would teach women
do you think it's better to have kids
when you're younger yeah
closer together
what and closer together and closer
together
okay what if you do them closer together
when you're younger and then you're like
40 and then you actually have an
accident later
i think you're very supportive towards
women
yeah i guess
um
was there any difference being pregnant
in your 20s teenagers and be in your 30s
or did it feel the same
because you literally had a kid in every
decade of your life minus like
like
40
decade that you really can i guess some
girls do it at four days but it's not
um when i was in better shape it was
much easier
when you like ran the marathon was that
your easiest pregnancy yeah really
[Music]
what was that eva yeah
because you were like pretty heavy when
you're in ego right yeah and you started
like losing weight and stuff
um
it's not an opinion well yeah of course
it's easier to get
um
what percentage of men do you think are
husband material what percentage of
women do you think are wife material do
you think it's equal
um
i think that there's less women
women today are that
there's more women than men on the
planet
do you want me to have a lot of kids i
want you to have as many kids as you
want to have right there i thought you
wanted me to have as many as possible
because you wanted a lot of grand
problems i do want a lot of great kids
no i want you to have as many kids as
you think you want to have i think i
want four i would love it
you don't how many do you want me to
have bad you guys can pick you can sort
it out
i think four is a really good number
like not too many but it's uh
it's like still affordable
i need at least two i'd be sad if i only
have one but i'd be fine with you
yeah so i guess i would say don't have
one
oh my gosh this guy said i will tax you
royally for owning what is vention
blinds
venetian blind what is that
we don't even own venetian blinds
i don't even know what those are it's
the types of lines that go up vertically
oh really
yeah i don't think we have those sir do
your research
um
oh my gosh i didn't realize women spend
80k to freeze their eggs and still have
not gotten pregnant
um what is the biggest age gap that
someone should have between each other
um depends on how old they are when they
um each other
the older you are the more it can be
now um
drizz i skipped your question because
she answered that earlier in the live
um
okay so if i'm
so if i'm 25 what's the oldest
45 too old
what about um
what about if i was 50.
then it doesn't matter
like can't be in the 20s
really so if i was 50 and i dated a 75
year old guy that'd be too much
and it all depends like there's a lot of
75 year olds but that's like fifty year
olds and there's a lot of fifty year
olds that act like they're eighty so um
[Music]
how is adoption expensive
how expensive is adoption if you adopt a
baby i think like 20k
i feel like if i had to pick between
like they said this girl spent 80k and
still didn't get pregnant i like i think
i would just adopt at that point
international babies are really
expensive together like
because i feel like 20k is doable 80k
for a maybe like you might get pregnant
um
that's so sad
like i think that i would just adopt at
that point
because uh
she probably got sold the bill of goods
that she can have kids whatever you want
[Music]
my god designs things a certain way
can you make me another crave
um let me finish the rice first
um
oh that was really dumb
i forgot it's for the hannah can you
help me
i got butter over with my hands before i
poured the rice krispies on the pan
pour taste of rice krispies dump them
out
okay
because i need to like scoop it down
that's hard oh wow my shoulder is like
randomly like pinches so bad
i think i'm going to get a shoulder
surgery whenever i want to start having
kids
okay because then i'm like not gonna be
playing sports anyway
so i'll do it right before i snatch
returner like
his
advice on
just the process like when you go get
strong first or like you know yeah
it's just things
that my hands are no longer buttery
do you think that um marriage is um
like do you think it's about love or
it's about duty
i think it's both
when do you think is an okay time to get
divorced like when do you think people
just like quitting because it's hard
i think uh dr laura
i always liked what she said even though
she was crazy but she always said uh
adultery abuse or alcoholism or
something like that addiction
like the three a's
the manuscript doesn't think cheating
counts for guys
i would disagree with it
but i think it's all circumstantial i
think that it depends you think if a guy
cheats because his wife isn't sleeping
with him that he should be given like
another chance maybe like if she hasn't
slept with him in like two years yeah
use it abuse
abuse adultery and addiction
would be like
solid reasons but like the idea of like
running you know people say we ran out
of love that's like selling your car
when you run out of gas
you gotta go create it
the ideal age for a girl to get married
do you think for me in my opinion yeah
i'm
23 23
maybe 25.
so i gotta get moving
[Music]
the average age is 27 did you know that
for girls anyway
you think it's the same for guys
how old um
minimum 25. okay
um
depends on the guy but
do you think that
our generation is more promiscuous than
your generation
yes i'm not even close all right my
theory is that they're equally
promiscuous we just had no consequences
and you guys had consequences
i mean the pill was pretty important you
were in high school well
maybe i should say
you think so
you know a lot of girls that were on the
phone in high school oh really
you know people had morals
morals
no how did you get pregnant you just run
on the pill
no
okay
damn so you're just like risking it all
um
do you think that marriage is too risky
for guys today because women can like
leave and take half
why
because i think they have to marry right
well if 50 of marriages end in divorce
do you think that you know do you think
it's more like
you can make sure you're part of the
video
that doesn't
okay
someone said you don't think people were
sleeping around in the free love era in
the 70s i don't i'm not saying that they
didn't and saying it
where it is now i think all of the boobs
hanging out with the
funny things
i genuinely don't think people have
changed i just think there's more
consequences now yeah i don't i
completely disagree
i talked to
a group of teenagers
and i was like
horrified at the things they were
willing to do
girls didn't sleep with more than one
guy
interested in a boyfriend
[Music]
i would marry the woman i love but not
on the books way too risky of a move i
can't predict 10 years into the future
so one guy says he would not marry her
on what on the books okay he said he'd
marry her like in a church or whatever
but he doesn't want to do it with the
state because
it's like too risky because women can
literally like leaving half of your
assets
so i don't know i kind of understand why
guys don't want to get married anymore
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't tell them not
to because i think it's like important
but
okay you still want to create
no i think i'm okay now
oh good luck
we all say i agree i'm not the
atmosphere is very against marriage
like women have created that situation
yeah that's true
if i ever run for office that's i feel
like if you can if you are fighting for
child custody it should start with 50 50
with the man and the woman
like um like that's where it should
start and then like if the husband's
like an alcoholic or something then like
it goes more to the girl or whatever do
you think that's true or false
i think it's false
i think that's circumstantial
really
the husband leaves
his wife and then wants to take the kids
well it's eighty percent of the time
women file for divorce
eighty percent if they're college
educated it's ninety percent
[Music]
oh that's a good idea actually
um except first she's making beat up
yeah well the same like the same things
you said
um
so jen i made um
all of the ingredients for breakfast
burritos okay sweet
i also was trying to make crepes okay
what would you like
oh that sounds good i mean
can you be a mod oh i got a 10 donation
thank you
um
yeah i think you're a moderator
you know breakfast burrito or crepe
[Music]
crepe
okay okay so um
i don't know exactly what i don't know
i've been making them with nutella and
peanut butter
is that
um how about if okay can i put it on a
tortilla instead of a bracelet because
these are really hard to manage okay and
they like crack a little part okay sure
mom what do you think
about dudes that want a 50-50
relationship slash marriage
you think that's okay
like like paying for everything like
everything's 50 50.
i think if that's what people want to do
they can do that
okay
you wouldn't recommend we do that though
no
someone paid ten dollars for that
question oh that was nice thank you
i'm just gonna heat up your tortilla a
little bit
and then
[Music]
okay what you just had to answer yes or
no hannah and they give you ten dollars
no it's like i can't give an explanation
no it's like so it's a live stream so
people can like watch us like cooking
and so i put q a so people put their
questions in the chat
but if you have like a question some
people just donate to be nice because
they appreciate your content but other
times like if they want if there's a lot
of questions in the chat and they want
theirs to be read then like they'll
donate money
so it's not like sometimes i get
donations multiple people answering me
uh well i did q a with my mom so i
didn't like
okay because i think a lot of people are
fascinated by like
like we've had nine siblings like your
parents are still married like
um
so i talk about my parents a lot like on
my channel so like sometimes i just
bring my parents
um
can you say that you were with the
person that you want to marry
back to that question yeah go ahead
i think
um
generally women want to be taken care of
and if you're 50 50 that's not really
feeling like you're taken care of and so
not every situation but yeah because
poor people have to get married too you
know yeah but
i think girls like generally want a guy
that's a little bit smarter than them or
like a little bit like makes a little
more than they do um
well can i say i'm with the person i'm
gonna marry no cause i broke up with him
um
um did you guys grow did we grow up
around other big families um
like the
were benign yeah um the michelski yeah i
would say
not as big as us but like four-ish i
grew up a lot around a lot of people
with four kids which i'd say is bigger
nowadays
the nicknames the michelle's
and you guys were in that apartment and
you were both a little bit melting down
and i was like oh my god i don't know
how they're gonna survive with one and
then like you came back like a few years
later when jessica was born right and it
was like the seas had parted like
everybody figured it out i was like
that's what it was
like wow
these are the same two people that i
wasn't sure i should leave alone
and then like suddenly
next time i see you guys i think you had
three because i don't think i saw you
oh no that was james how many how many
kids do you recommend people have four
before
do you wish
like all half of us didn't exist
you guys we went to the cabin with him
at awesome
yeah and you guys were like
in nuclear meltdowns
[Music]
um
so you think i should have four kids
grandkids okay well i was six just like
too stressful
it's just everything is it's not that
it's bad it's like
after four you have to start buying
special vehicles because no standard
vehicles
yeah i mean you get seven fat passenger
van
how old were you when you got married
what was that 27. that's my dad i was
wedding that was the first time i was in
california
you and my dad like got married around
the same time because my dad was 27
right you were 22 i was 20 i was 21 and
he was are you 21 when you got married
yeah oh no you were 23 when you had
austin yeah okay okay
wow that's crazy
i was like
i just
um
[Music]
yeah i know and i'm like i'm like trying
to figure out how to make these so that
oh this is an interesting question
hannah's was not very uh
it was good though
okay this mom do you agree with this or
not a man cannot have boun a man cannot
have boundaries if his woman knows that
he'll never leave
leave her and obviously he'll never
leave if she can take half the money
okay repeat that again like i think he's
saying a man cannot have boundaries if
his woman knows he'll never leave and
obviously he'll never leave if she can
take half the money
like do you were you afraid dad was
gonna leave you
i don't know why half the money would
make you stop from divorcing
yeah
it does it doesn't you don't think so
i mean it'll make you think a little
longer about it
because that's a lot you know it could
be a lot of money right but yeah
do you think a girl is entitled to half
the money if she like married him young
and he like like she stayed home with
the kids while he went to work
yeah really you think half
probably i don't know i have mixed
feelings
i went to lunch once with a client of
ours
a really successful guy actually and he
uh i told john this the other day i was
so
amazed by his perspective like i was
asking about his wife and
he said well she stays home with kids
and like how old are your kids and
they're like in fifth and seventh grade
and i was like oh i'm surprised like
she'd go back to work and he said well
she literally does everything i was like
what do you mean he goes
all i do is bring home a disposable
paycheck she does everything else she
knows where the kids is doctors are she
knows the groceries makes the dinner
does sports figures out schools
she pays our bills she does
literally everything he's like the only
thing i do is disposable anybody can
bring home a paycheck
and i just was like oh is he said he
said but it would stop me i ain't trying
to lose half my [ __ ]
forever so mary right
oh my gosh that's so funny
i think kids get in the way of drinking
did your kids get in the way of your
dreams yeah
because i saw so many old people who
were so lonely and so sad
that
do you believe in prenups
like do you think prenups are okay
i've been different
i feel like i wouldn't
i think i should get a prenup
um i think that's circumstantial
do you think that men should go find
wives outside of america
if they want
to sometimes the chat asks the strangest
questions
i don't think we'll have to i think all
the people are coming here they're
coming
the mail order bride business is failing
what country do you want to meet someone
from they're all coming in
um what's what's your advice to the new
generation of marriage on marriages
because like mary just done so
differently than when you were younger
[Music]
go back to traditional
[Laughter]
do you think would you ever allow austin
um
and
adam to
date a single mom
um well i guess allowed they could do
what they want but would you be cool
with it
i'm gonna confirm it depends on the
situation
yeah like what if she's i don't like
brass brush strokes i guess is what i
would say what if she was widowed
i think it's up more they have to know
what they're signing up for because i
would not allow them to be
banned step dads
they have to be all in
do you feel like someone in the
manuscript said that if you sign up to
be a step dad you should have like the
legal rights of the father because
you're like more in the home than he's
going to be
so like you should be able to legally
like adopt them
no i don't think so there's a lot of
good dads for a divorce
okay
i think that's a really hard roll
what if the dad sound in the picture
for sure then yeah
um okay i have a normal question
should i pay off debt as soon as
possible or should i wait a little bit
later and build a credit score
absolutely
pay off that
um
what do you think of the western
progressive ideology is it worsening
society or making it better
your mom is straight so straightforward
and honest i see where you get it from
[Laughter]
[Music]
how's your arms on
just my right
my shoulder like
it's like worse i don't know why
those rice crispy treats hurt yeah
would i ever get with a guy that's
polygamous but is very respectful
he can respectfully cheat no
actually have you heard of that mom they
call it cheating respectfully
it is
yeah they're like they're like wait if
you don't bring home stds no outside
kids and she doesn't find out it's
respectful
[Laughter]
do you think that if you're a step dad
you should have the right to discipline
the kids like if a girl is going to
marry you and like like he should have
to work that out in advance how that
sits but i think
he has to have some authority um
i think that's really really really hard
um
[Music]
do you think there's honor in being a
stepdad yeah
yeah
raising somebody else's kids is very
very very very hard do you think they
should have some sort of rights like
let's say um i get married you gotta
have a kid and he raises a kid from like
two to seven and then we break up do you
think that he should have any rights to
like see the kids or anything yeah
so like there should be something legal
because that's why they talk about it's
like a lot of guys don't want to sign up
because they get to know the kid and if
it doesn't work out it's like yeah can
you put um the mastercard
you could check for a credit like 40
grand for nurses
um
sure
3189 yeah
it's not really cheating if you know
about it beforehand i
guess you know it's just sleeping around
it's not a relationship
they'll say
um
[Music]
oh my gosh wait
um
mom why do you frown upon polygamy when
it's literally a practice that's been
successful and happy for women and
for thousands of years in muslim
countries
um
[Music]
i don't want us to answer that because
that's like i can't answer
got ice cream but it was a dollar ice
cream so they could afford that
that guy stayed in the van they brought
him what do you what do you think about
a movement i'm starting called give back
our rights
so i'm i'm like i hate driving so i'm
gonna give that one back
um i'm like why work let's give that
back too
why vote like we have to let the guys do
that let's give it back
so i'm gonna call it return
and then like that way like i just don't
have to do anything
is being a good cook impressive to women
like guy being a good cook oh i think
that's nice i think any skill that a guy
has is impressive to girls yeah i would
say because it like shows you're smart
um ask your mom what i said about step
kids he said i'm not giving my time and
energy and resources and attention and
money to another man's kids i'm not
allowed to discipline in my own house
that's the dumbest deal i've ever heard
but i said he should be able to
discipline them i think they need to
work out the yeah arrangement in advance
but
i think that's
i think that's a really really hard role
i have a lot of respect for men who do
that because i think it's really really
hard
and i think that
like that's probably the number one
chafe that happens in second marriages
is like
when they don't figure out how to how to
do that effectively yeah
um okay brad i answered your question
are you happy he was very upset i didn't
read that one
oh but you answered it right um what
makes a guy romantic do you think a girl
should date a broke guy
i guess if she's broke
[Laughter]
i don't know like like that seems like
they are very fixated on the financial
side of it and
that just didn't really
occur to me
well yeah you're 21 how much money could
he have
i had more than him and we both had none
like
uh wait wait what
he always says you married potential
that he always tells me very potential
well i mean i think you i mean you
probably knew he was going to be
successful i never thought about it
really never even
never i guess because you weren't like
attracted to his work ethic like that
wasn't attractive to you
i didn't know it
he wasn't crazy done
um
i'm just imagining it like i can't
imagine dad not working
um
no i think a good work ethic but that
doesn't necessarily mean you're going to
be
wealthy yeah no i know
like wealth happens as a result of pers
of hard work pursuing things
that bring you joy or you know
it isn't like
there's very few people that just go get
rich
[Music]
okay um okay i can't figure out how to
check this for him but what makes a guy
romantic if he doesn't have money to
take her on like a nice date uh i think
that the most romantic things are far
that cost absolutely nothing i know one
of the most romantic things
dad ever did
what um was it the penny thing oh that
was really special too um he
no he went we went for a walk up here
and i didn't realize that he was picking
up flowers the whole way and he came
back and gave me a bouquet of
right here
that was so sweet
so so the point was is that
most of the things that he's done
most of my very very favorite things
cost nothing
and the only
the only expensive things that he ever
did
which was like buying me my heart
necklace
but
it was valuable because it was really
thoughtful not because it was expensive
so that's what i would say
society looks at men with multiple
families in a bad way but it's actually
a huge responsibility he's the financial
aid and support and emotionally support
three families that's a very tough thing
to do oh i think he's talking about that
yeah
but i just don't think women that would
make women happy
do you think i should focus on having
kids now or our career
um i think you should do what you want
to do
i think in the right circumstance you
can go have kids but
that's not uh
i don't think you need something to fall
back on for a career okay why can't i
say this is super annoying
my mom already said men should settle
down when they're 25 or older
what do you think john
it seems to be a fairly ideal age if
you're talking to the age to marry yeah
yeah um yeah
these studies have shown there are less
divorces between 27 and 32 something
like that that that was an ideal tonight
right i guess people are you kind of
what they want to do in life and
check the other person out make sure
they know what they want to do in life
as opposed to maybe just meeting in high
school and you don't know what you're
going to do or what they're going to be
like
i think like
i remember i can't figure this out for
him
when i was 40
like i had friends who were older most
of our friends were older than me
um
can a guy only look romantic after
you've known him for a while or can it
be from the first date would you tell a
guy to aim to be romantic on the first
date
i think romantic isn't about like
flowers and chocolates
i think it's about being genuine
that's true because i feel like
it's like about getting a gift you know
the other person would really like
and it's even better when you didn't
tell them what to get yeah i'm really
bad at that gift giving is not my strong
suit
actually i think i gave you the best
gift ever
a song yeah oh that was a great gift
um
[ __ ] that produced one gifts are the
best
having a husband and kids is fulfilling
to women no 50 year old woman has ever
said i'm lonely
without a husband and kids but at least
i have a good career
well she says thank god i've got a good
career because otherwise my life sucks
how many guys have you put in the friend
zone
i mean
i've been with dad since i was 17 so
all of them
like every um a guy can do you think men
and women can be just friends yeah
they like seriously don't think they can
in the mana sphere
i disagree do you think men and women
can be friends
you mean like after they're married yeah
just like no like
you and i being friends or yeah
i mean i have a good one of my best
friends growing up his sister is awesome
kind of like a friend that i need
and
it's not that we spend a lot of time
together i'd probably not be very good
for him but no i don't mind it wouldn't
be like weird if i said to lisa that i
would go over and visit her go for a
walk
have coffee with her
every year or two i mean you
a level of friendship and intimate it's
kind of maybe the level of friendship or
interest like there's a line where it's
kind of weird but like right like but
yeah and it helps if your spouse knows
them and knows that they've been just
you know a friend maybe for a long time
and that they know that's the level of
intimacy you're looking for when you
talk to them is just hey how's things
going to catch me up on your life
someone said all women are trash
what mom what advice would you give for
a long-term relationship after the
honeymoon phase and the butterflies are
over
um
i tried making homemade crepes at them
and
actually they taste quite good here i
like the
this is mom
stop
the design hasn't been so good
but they're actually quite tasty
um
how was your burritos it was good thanks
do you think men and women can be
friends yeah
i have a lot of female friends
have you hooked up with any of them most
of them
but i don't anymore i did one time one
time
it defeats the whole purpose
you can be friends without having to
hook up
okay i'm really excited for you to
explain this to your wife one day
you can be
uh what eight mom at what age should he
stop being a loner i would say as soon
as possible
mom this one guy wants to know if i'd be
open to dating the guy that made the
hate video on me after he becomes the
pope
i yeah you know he seems like a great
great guy
i told you he said i was the like spot
like um
jezebel
how could he say you were the jezebel
just to be nasty
i don't know
no i i'll show it to you later
don't play it out
how many people are watching the fan
like 20.
i made 15
dollars will i be your friend uh no
[Laughter]
well
he's not popular enough for me to just
look up his name
um
ask them about your comment about men
and women being friends i think men and
women can be friends but if the guy
doesn't have get any woman then he
probably has an agenda in the friendship
it's easier for a man to be genuine
that's good
stop it's easier for a man that's good
with women to be genuine
this guy
no
i'll show it to you later
but yeah you can totally be friends with
them
i think i feel like if you've slept
together like i think that's where
you're not friends anymore i'm just i'm
kelly and i are good friends
because of the fact that we slept
together
oh we never have signs
wow
i cannot wait for you to explain that to
your wife
i totally would
think she'd enjoy the story
what do you think mom do you think
adam's future wife is going to be okay
with that
slept with a girl and now they're just
friends
and do you think like there's a lot that
i'm like that i'm not looking forward to
do
okay adam slept with all of his female
friends
okay the female friends that adam slept
with do you think him and hit them are
just friends
[Laughter]
you can be friends with a girl that
you've slept with and never slept with
again
and you can be friends with the woman
that you sleep with frequently like
there's things i can't wait
i can't wait for you to explain this to
your future
wife i cannot wait [ __ ] there's a girl i
call my wife i've never slept with her
but i think it's hilarious how do you
think that would go in a marriage like
calling someone else
[Laughter]
someone said you're the real pope
yeah but i don't have an agenda because
i don't care
thank you
guys if you've been watching for more
than five minutes send a donation help a
girl out i'm trying to buy a backdrop
for my youtube channel most guys have a
hard time friendzoning yeah well it's
probably because you don't sleep with
another woman
oh my god i don't have a hard time
friends anymore at all it's kind of fun
you're also 6'4
that's what i tell girls at the bar i'm
like this is my brother he's 6'4
i don't know why i can't get the live
chat to like stay i keep having to like
put it up
most guys like friends with benefits
better than relationships because you
get all the good things out of the woman
without the negativity and the drama
yeah are you drunk someone wants to know
no
can your
dunk okay
you can dunk yeah
i don't even know you really played
basketball i hate basketball
it was the only thing that i wanted to
learn how to do just so i could say i
could do it
do you feel like you have game adam
you said
you gotta have game a 6-4 dork is still
a 6-4 dork do you think you have a game
yeah
i think everybody does they just don't
know how to use it
isn't friends with benefits incompatible
with being catholic
we need more men like your brother in
society
the internet is so funny
um
do you think women should not have the
ability to vote do you think it's
redundant and efficient with them
joining in on consequential uncon do you
think it's wait do you think it's
redundant and inefficient with them
joining on consequential consequential
political decisions um i want to be
honest i want to give back all of my
rights so
[Laughter]
i'm returning
i can tell adam has game just from this
video
do you think we're disappointments in
the family
do you think we're
you think we're we would love to hear
your version of um
of this when you tell your wife
look at it
i think we disappoint our mother i'm not
gonna lie to you
it happens
fun fact women don't want the right to
vote
because they that meant they would be
eligible to be drafted for the war men
gave them the right because they thought
that was the right thing to do
okay i i kid guys peter parker they're
both awesome
called just chat things chess chad oh
chad
but you're six four
are you going to get married i'll take a
crepe properly
um
peanut butter yup
do you think i should make an nft
no why you're stupid
it's yeah online sticker essentially
your brother looks like your brother
looks like he would
[ __ ]
your brother looks like he write an
image online do you want a crepe
non-fungi
[Music]
your brother looks like you would sue me
for no reason
you pay to get a digital stamp on it
altered don't get married bro just send
me half of your money instead
similar action people sell them
for ridiculous amounts of money
just very very speculative it's like
they watch people that are young
they think potentially good artists and
based on that
they speculate that their artwork will
go up in price and so they pay
sometimes tens of thousands of dollars
for this
very speculative
so you think would you break up with a
girl she wouldn't learn would you would
you be okay if she would learn how to
cook yeah i think okay
is there are
ask your brother is there a height for a
girl below that you wouldn't negdate a
date for example would you date a girl
that's five one
first girl i ever dated was 5'4
some of it's interesting to look at oh
it kind of depends i don't think i'd
really care about the height yeah to be
honest with you
adam is a four
man they made me better looking than you
they call me a five
but he has six four height plus he uh
the six four height he gets plus two so
then you become a six
and looks plus having a
multi-millionaire father he's an eight
mother there's a handful of
artists i guess
thank you thank you hurt his feelings
really crazy um
do you have any volleyball tips for a
beginner um
yeah i mean it depends how beginner you
are but the first thing you need to do
is learn how to pass
um and i would just get like
experience in a game and just play as
much as you can you need to learn how to
pass and serve that's what you need to
learn first your chances of winning
because you can't set or hit if you
can't get the pass up
yeah no we're not in england we're in
denver right now
adam would you date a girl that's six
five yeah you're hilarious
you'd marry her six five
yeah
i loved her
okay no we're in breckenridge so if she
was five one then you'd date her
okay so you don't really care about
height
if she's hot she's hot yeah okay you
know they're 23.
guys if you've been watching for more
than five minutes send a super chat it's
too physically dangerous
i don't know man you gotta enjoy the
dangerous side of life i love my woman
so i wouldn't allow her to do any hobby
that is
dangerous
i think most girls don't want to do
dangerous things anyway yeah
my hobbies climbing out of cars while
we're going 40 miles an hour
y'all would have like yao main kids
ew
[Laughter]
there's no way an adam adam is oh
they're arguing they said you're you're
higher than a four there's no way adam
is a four looks wise he's more like a
6.5 play base plus two for heights plus
two for a wealthy family therefore
10.5 adam this person rates you at a 10
and a half like you broke the scale out
of 100. they always rate me at
um if they're mad at me they say you're
four
four at best and if they're happy with
me they rate me a seven so
business and advice for men
i don't have any
it don't take nice
one
someday
bro y'all getting at the calculus
no
it's too weird of a section of youtube
it's like
a very odd
sector of you a little bit too much
peanut butter mother
some people my tic-tock lives will be
people i know or maybe instagram but no
not youtube oh this is a youtube yeah
the guy from last night
oh the guy last night that was someone i
know from tick tock i met him when i was
in l.a he does like the bachelor gossip
channel
so he just requested to be in my live on
tick tock and i accepted
um we always fly coach we never fly
first class
unless we want to start mom
thirty dollar
trip is a thirty dollar trip man
we don't even pay for a signed seat yeah
thirty dollar trip is a very dollar trip
i don't know these other dudes okay i'm
not saying every person that watches the
man of sphere is weird i'm saying the
manuscript is an odd sector of youtube
[Music]
mom i changed my mind can i have one now
i think a man should be 80 selfish and
20 selfless
i don't know about that
you should be mostly selfless
no matter who you are woman or man
i only watch you i'm your internet
stalker you're an internet soccer hannah
who oh i've always wanted a stalker
oh wow
please don't hunt me down or anything
i'd be like really annoying what less of
everything but the same yeah
oh i think i put it in the sink because
i thought i was done
pearly is a oh i'm a 6.5 base wow
oh and i'm physically fit
and i get a point for being in a wealthy
family
and i get two points for being a
rational thinker
mom i'm an 11.50
i broke this
i broke the scale that's okay i don't
even want rides
you should drop my tinder profile and
ask them how to fix it
um
okay
so you could show your tinder profile on
the live
no you should drop my tinder profile and
ask them how to fix it
what do you mean drop it like right post
or put it as a post and say how do i get
my brothers oh my god mom your hair is
in my ew
is the last one making for you
yeah um
[Music]
guys say they want a woman to cook and
clean
but i think the root is this they want
to know their woman is attracted to them
and will do things for them
[Music]
what do i disagree with donovan sharp um
um
that men
don't men don't cheat they have sex with
other people
emotional reasons
no i think
um
i agree with that i think they cheat
differently but it's still cheating like
how are you
very good
okay so the file that i sent you
apparently too big that's why you
couldn't
if i had money i would just pay a stuff
and i made i don't want my woman to cook
and clean oh my gosh that's what i want
a chef and a maid and let me do like
video editing and like marketing and
[ __ ] in september and she canceled it
like the day i called you or i messaged
you and so i'm a little bit in a between
a rock and a hard place because
we do family jammies every year for
christmas
and this was my idea so
it was going to be printed on not just
me
um
no
i think women
i are more attracted to certain
professions for sure
um if there's
like i do think
but i think it's more about how you
carry yourself so if a woman doesn't
like a blue collar guy it's probably
because of like
the way he carries himself more than
like his job
um
yeah have ever been cheated on before
i don't know
and i don't know i can just kick myself
for not thinking you in september
instead of going on etsy because i just
didn't even
you know i've been waiting for somebody
like you to do what you've been doing
for me for like 20 years
and so in the powerpoint i think it's
more about social class than actual
because if a guy was raised in like a
certain social class and he
chose to be a plumber because of the
money that's different than like
a guy in a lower social class becoming a
plumber
like
i don't know if that makes sense
but i think it's more about social class
than necessarily the job
um
okay guys
okay guys i'm gonna end the live because
i've been on here for an hour and a half
but thank you
so much for watching and all the
questions this was so fun
[Music]
let me know
what you guys want to do next time